you think humor is more of a factor I
guess in mate selection than height I
think they're both important I think
women seem to have this rule of thumb
that I I want a guy who's at least as
tall as me and preferably at least a
couple inches taller than me
particularly if you're tall if you can
kind of convince yourself to relax this
height standard it really broadens your
mating pool and then you can focus on
all these other traits that you care
about but man if you go on Tinder and
you say okay I need somebody at least
six feet tall he's making at least six
figure income a lot of men won't fit
that who might have made great
boyfriends or husbands think about it
objectively in the modern world is there
actually any difference in terms of
capability as a husband or father
between a guy who's five nine versus six
one